you're progressive in one way and then
but you're still making that [ __ ]
backward oh story of about seven dwarves
living in a cave what the [ __ ] are you
doing man peter dinklage isn't feeling
disney's upcoming live-action remake of
snow white and the seven dwarfs
there's a lot of hypocrisy going on i
gotta say from being a
somebody who's a little
bit unique
the game of thrones star who has a form
of dwarfism slammed disney during an
interview on mark maron's wtf podcast
saying that while he thinks the studio
took one step forward casting the lead
they took two giant steps backward
perpetuating old stereotypes i was a
little taken back by the
very very they're very proud to cast a a
a latino actress as snow white yeah but
you're still telling the story of snow
snow white yeah
sure take a step back and look at what
you're doing there it makes no sense to
me you're progressive in one way and
then but you're still making that
[ __ ] backward oh story of about seven
dwarves
living in a cave what the [ __ ] are you
doing man following peter's remarks a
spokesperson for disney told et in a
statement quote to avoid reinforcing
stereotypes from the original animated
film we are taking a different approach
with these seven characters and have
been consulting with members of the
dwarfism community we look forward to
sharing more as the film heads into
production after a lengthy development
period
have i done nothing to advance the cause
from my soapbox i guess i'm not loud
enough yeah i don't know what studio
that is but there but it was they were
so proud of that and all love and
respect to the to the actress and to
the people who thought they were doing
the right thing but i'm just like you
know what are you doing as of now it's
unknown how producers will portray the
seven dwarfs but we do know west side
story star rachel zegler has been cast
as snow white thank you so much oh my
god following the casting news the 20
year old actress shared her excitement
on instagram writing quote well hello to
a dream come true rachel will join gal
gadot who is set to portray the evil
queen
it's all new news to
we just broke out with this news and i'm
very very very excited and looking
forward
to to play the evil queen
mirror mirror on the wall
but back to peter the 52 year old actor
added that if disney is going to move
forward with a live-action remake of the
film its storyline should be updated
if you tell them to tell
the the story of snow white yeah its
most step cool
progressive spin on it
let's do it yeah uh all in
not only did he weigh in on the snow
white remake peter who played tyrion
lannister on game of thrones gave his
two cents on the show's upcoming prequel
house of the dragon
i think it's going to be a really good
show i think it's gonna be really
[ __ ] good they took a huge risk on
our show and
it was it was a slow start but why don't
they do that again right but this isn't
a risk it's it's a proven thing
you